I see a lot of these motivational
speakers
telling you what you need to do and how
you have to go out there and grab life
and don't be afraid and go to the
mountain and when you get to that
mountain build another mountain and blah
blah blah
you got all the answers
you're born with common sense you may
not believe it but you have the answers
they're in better than there you know
them just like all of a sudden what they
gave them wisdom and not you come on we
all have it I believe a lot of it is in
our DNA
we're programmed to
survive not just exist to survive
Prosper go forward blah blah you get it
so what I'm saying to you is this a lot
of these guys women have good ideas
they're very motivational but motivate
yourself because you have the instincts
you have the knowledge the lesson lies
in learning and by teaching you'll be
taught it's all there anyway just needs
to be sought sought out take those
thoughts they're embedded in your brain
that you already know
the difference between right and wrong
and how to succeed how do you succeed
perseverance just keep trying keep
trying it's not that hard not that
complicated
I notice every
year people make resolutions and maybe
five percent sick
because somehow along the way we sort of
lose track of that ambition that thought
and we say I don't know if I can handle
this and I guess the word is we quit I
have certainly on many times but
sometimes the word quitting gets a bad
rap
by that I mean
if you're on the wrong path you're on
the wrong trail you're going after
something and it's just not working
period it's just not flowing naturally
and you've been at it for a while you go
I quit good
I did and it opened up a thousand new
doors for me
so sometimes quitting is necessary
to find your proper place in the world
by that I mean in the early 70s I went
to New York with great ambition
didn't know a person like eight nine
million people and me not one person and
I would say to be an actor and let me
just tell you that was
a bomb out man that I crater it was not
pretty so rather than completely go back
and maybe drive a forklift somewhere I
went said okay you know I really do love
the film business I love stories I love
telling stories I'm not that good at it
at least I had never proven myself and I
started to write and I were going to
movie theaters with a really cheesy
typical I record the dialogue I think
the first film I did was Easy Rider and
then I would try to write different
dialogue kind of a contest
not that I succeeded but it's the effort
that counts but
slowly but surely I thought wow each
screenplay
is getting better the first five
you wouldn't line your bird cage with it
nope you wouldn't train your puppy on it
nope
floating around the fifth and sixth one
ah not bad and if I had never done that
I would be talking to you today
because I had to go out and write my way
into my future no one was giving it to
me I wasn't one of those lucky guys that
oh you're in the right place at the
right time you're just exactly what
we're looking for when just the opposite
was true they said ah you're not what
we're looking for
you know you slur you're this you're
that you're kind of a type you're
thuggish or whatever term they use and
some of it was some of it was
pretty damn brutal today I look back on
it with humor but at the time it hurts
because words hurt words are verbal
bullets and they can shred you but I
just turned the deaf ear to it because I
had no other recourse I was gonna be
something in this business not an actor
not a director but a writer which was
the longest shot ever so in conclusion
sometimes quitting is great quitting
causes you to go in a different
direction that you normally wouldn't
have gone in and where you thought I
could never succeed in this and lo and
behold that door opens and all of a
sudden Destiny pulls you through
it happened to me the fact that it
happened to me is definitely proof that
it can happen to everybody if you're
true to yourself you never know what
beats inside a guy's heart the exterior
belies the interior
so
I could go on and on about this but it
happens folks it happened to me it's
happened to thousands of people before
me everyone's a freaking Underdog even
the guys that were are billionaires they
started out as underdogs no one gave it
to them someone in the family perhaps
had to earn it and pass it on but that
first one the guy that went into the
unknown
unprepared but prepared mentally but
perhaps unprepared for what was going to
come at him
from so many different directions and
when I say that come at him I mean those
obstacles that wanted to defeat him
including his own fear and they were
overcome so as Rocky would say
it ain't over till it's over
I was thinking the other day that even
though we're on dry land in reality life
is almost like living on water which is
a very very strong force in all water
that is a current and that current
will take you out to the ocean
where eventually you just get swallowed
up by the sure magnitude of everything
and
once you're out there you can't swim
back
it just takes you where it wants to go
and not where you want to go
and swimming against the current is
really a metaphor for life
just have to struggle
it's a struggle to achieve one's goals
which is really difficult it's hard
people tend to minimize
diminish the struggle that is just
getting by in life quite often it's just
easy to go with the current
but to be an individual to feel as
though you did your best in the game of
life and got to swim against the current
and boy it's fatiguing but when you get
to the other side you can climb
out of that water
and you're at the place you want to be
in that unexplored area kind of like
reminds me of the extraordinary optimism
of explorers imagine a thousand years
ago setting sail for the complete
unknown you have no idea at one time
they thought the Earth was flat you just
go over the side and you die but you
still would
where there's sea monsters or this event
I mean all kinds of dangers you're going
into an absolute Abyss
yet what keeps you going
if you know there's something better out
there
if you're willing
to face the danger
the unknown
that's the jury of life
and it's invigorating
we've always challenging